Yay!
Sunlin, Fala!
Hello everybody!
Yay!
Okay, I'm gonna try to get my...
I actually bought a...
I'm not so kidding!
I'm a horse!
I'm yay I can't sorry the only issue is that I can't move my
fingers I realize there was one thing I was missing I was
just like I got everything set up I find everything I need
and I was like because like you know like when dad's
birthday was going on dad does technically doesn't have
fingers so oh yeah I have no tail so I do I knew I forgot
something.
Because, like, I didn't notice it.
Because Dad doesn't have fingers.
So I was like, oh, man, this shit is insane.
And then I was like, oh, I can't move my hands.
I can't move my hands.
I can technically move my hands.
I can't move my fingers.
I just have claws.
That's all I have.
I have claws
Um, oh, yeah, but look
Okay, wait Also, I'm gonna test my Okay, I'm gonna sit down
because I need to test my I bought I bought wireless
headsets because I realized Um Oh, I realized like the other
issue Was that Uh, was that Um, whenever I'm away from my
mic, you can't Fucking hear me, so let me I bought wireless
headphones, so I don't know if this works.
Let me try it out.
I was charging.
I forgot to charge it.
I Bought wireless headphones and it has a mic.
So let me see if it works.
So it might sound weird.
So let me check.
Let me test this out.
I know we're doing it live.
Wait.
There we go.
Hello.
Okay, wait.
I'm going to change my mic source input to...
is this headset microphone hello oh am i too loud hello am i
okay am i okay oh i'm sorry
how about now i'm sorry how about okay i'll lower it how
about now oh my god do we have sound jack here do we have
sound we're testing it live right
how about now better do we want it to be lower not that low
okay wait alright so wait alright is this loud or is it too
crusty as fuck okay look this was expensive is it actually
crunchy this is okay wait I'm gonna meet myself hello hello
this this mic was this this headset was expensive but but
you guys can hear me now when I turn around is it really
Xbox qual okay wait what if I lower myself a little bit okay
I guess I need another headset mic all right wait okay I I
lowered myself a little bit more.
Is that better?
Okay, wait.
But I can get farther away now.
I just, I might need a better prescription.
Okay, wait, load.
Nay.
Wow.
Yeah, it sounds like crap.
No!
I will fade so much.
but it's not that bad i paid so much for this mic with this
headset because i was like oh i need like a wireless headset
so you know it makes sense you know to have a wireless
headset you know wait it might be the settings it sounds
okay if you talk a little bit hello okay wait i'll lower it
a bit more hello hello
I should go next to you they give the super chat they get
they I just I just wanted to have a wireless headset wait
actually I'm like tilted right now wait actually I can fix
this by doing watch this it's like magic wait is it like
magic oh no I just moved it wait how do I tilt my camera
what
Wait, no, no, I'm flying away now.
Wee.
Okay.
Um, there we go.
I don't remember how to do all of this.
This is all new technology.
New technology moment for me.
Okay, hold.
to look around i guess like this right all right there you
go yay oh wait i'm too too tall now there you go yay yay oh
oh wait wait wait wait wait okay all right sound guy sound
fix me fix my mic for me i don't know what else fix my mic
that's not plugged into my go xlr it's a by the way so
figure
horses kids yeah but it out but it out but down but um but
oh my gosh oh my god it's falling down the tractors are
falling down i don't want to cut circulation so last time i
actually took off my pants because the clothing the clothing
makes it so that it falls down all right if i lose my leg
it's because of on his new year or lunar new year I cut off
my circulation for it um do you have your mic settings from
your no um so this isn't connected to my go XLR so it's its
own little special thing I don't know because it's a
wireless headset no I just didn't wear pants last time so
then it wouldn't fall down but yes wait Mr. Beast.
I like, I'm like, yeah, this is like the alpha pose.
That's right.
Mindspread time.
Wait.
Mr. Beast.
Oh, maybe it did come up with software.
That's a good question.
Um, um...
It's a Corsair headset.
Okay, let me look this up.
Alright, we're doing it live.
I didn't know how I sounded.
So I was like, let me try it because I had to charge it.
Uh...
Let me look up this headphone.
It's a Corsair headset.
Alright.
Um...
let's see I can't believe it sounds like Xbox I Corsair is
not good my friend recommended this headset for me no
no no no no
it's okay this is just a test run this is the peak is no is
it really peaking no okay wait i can get it further away
from me all right the mic is further away now is it better
yeah i could take the mic off if i need it i just needed
something wireless because i want to turn around like this
and then i could i wanted to move away from the mic like
this i was tired of like um is it better oh it's better now
i'm sorry guys if i've been peaking have i been peaking
really badly the entire i'm so sorry i'm so yelling into
your ear we're doing it live
i'm doing it all live no no just not that all right legend
has a scream as loud as you can do it it will fix it right
thank you with a super chat thank you thank you okay uh your
mop your skin is moving like a dude that's too oh my gosh oh
my god i can't admit i can't do anything my hands are are
are stuck in rippers rar i knew i forgot one thing i was
like oh my god i got everything i need i got i've got
everything i need and then i was just like i got you know my
face and like like that and then i was just like you know i
can move my entire body now and everything and then i
realized i i can't move my fingers
it's stuck on rar mode it's forever stuck on rar
Law, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki, happy Lunar New Year.
I fell asleep during Dad's birthday and forgot to say it was
my birthday too.
Can you get a happy belated birthday?
Pray, please.
Of course you can.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Law.
Yay!
Happy birthday.
All right.
But is everything okay now, sound guy?
I might need to recalibrate.
I might take off my pants too.
It just keeps slipping.
I just wanted to twirl.
I wanted to like, you know, be like, wee.
And then you guys can all hear me when I'm doing that,
because like when we were experimenting during dad's
birthday, you couldn't hear him whenever he was.
wanted to whenever we want i wanted to twirl like this oh oh
before since it is lunar new year um wait i gotta remember
something important uh it doesn't sound bad just word oh
okay wait i can add a compression on it let's see
Add compressor.
Okay, a compressor is on.
Ah!
Wait, I'll give this...
I'll give the compressor settings to the sound people and
let them look at it.
I don't know what this looks like.
Don't do it.
Oh, wait.
Is it worse?
Oh, no.
Okay, I turned it off.
Okay, wait.
I'm going to message this to the audio people and let them
figure this out.
all right I turned it off because they said it was worse but
I'll give this to you guys and let you guys figure it out
all right all right okay so I also have this watch this um
let's see a new toy where is it where is it oh there it is
I'm at a very Chinese time of my life right now because I am
Chinese psych I'm Chinese for me fuck no for me I'm married
pro tip get passive income never get married no never get
married pro tip you're so real yeah for those who don't wait
actually wait let's see I have also have one wait where's my
one and then I also have which my other one I have two wait
I don't know how to use my hands apparently
please let me show the other okay that's fine you guys can
see two right here the other one's just not facing you all
right all right who's married any dragoons married in chat
any any dragoons married in chat right now show yourself
show show yourself guys any Me, all right, all right, Spark,
you know the rules.
Now, hand it over.
You know the rules.
It's tradition.
Hand it over.
It's a trap.
That's right.
You know the rules.
Married people have to give the lice form.
Why?
Why, Laisi?
I said it.
I said the good wishes.
Don't make me take it back.
That's bad luck.
That's really bad luck.
I said my wishes.
I said good health, good fortune.
You don't want me to take that back, do you?
Here's some red envelope for you.
Fun.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
if I could I would if I could I would ball my hands up right
now but I can't my hands don't work up here my fingers don't
work right now um uh public thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you yeah I don't get married guys it just
got married oh congratulations congratulations on getting
married
I got new sound settings.
All right, we're going to try this out.
All right.
Ratio.
Three.
Get ratio there.
Oh, one.
Uh, 20.
Wait, 25?
As in 25.
Okay.
20 oh minus 25 minus 25 and then set to 10 all right new
sound settings all right how do i sound testing testing
hello i can move i can pitch myself higher no i can make
myself louder too if it's too quiet we're testing the
wireless mic right now because i want to twirl i want to be
able do this and then walk away and you guys can still hear
me and i'm gonna go get milk right now
i want to be able to do that you know just that's very quiet
okay wait i can move it i can up myself hello hello hello
okay now i'm i'm a bit louder now look whoa i can like do
the monte
I'm gonna shake my booty.
I knew I forgot something too.
I forgot the tail.
I forgot a lot of things.
I've got the kicks.
Look at that.
That's right.
I can do like the Street Fighter AFK shit like this way.
Being like, ha, ha, ha.
And then ha.
And then A, A, A, A, B.
Am I loud enough now?
Airborne Ninja, thank you for the Aka Super.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the Aka Super.
Thank you, thank you for the Aka Super.
Thank you, thank you.
Like that.
Oh, Alex, I can do that.
In my humidifier, I'll be like, Oh my God, I can't.
My legs are too long.
My legs...
I can Wait
Allie kick out Allie kick out
Please do this on Okay, you guys want green screen?
I can actually get on a green screen right now Let me see
Oh, I'm good on get on green screen for you guys Let me find
it real quick all right we're blue we're purple all right
purple screen because technically i mean i think you guys
can work with my eyes are green so we're on so i'll get on
an earple screen for you because my eyes are green all right
be like yeah the sway and then the oh my god i hit my door i
and then twirl establishing dominance with this that's right
I'm establishing dominance right now
wait okay my volume okay now champ is my is my volume okay
whoa
was my volume okay now we can hear pretty good that's good
that's good to know okay wait wait all right and then home
bow here's some red pocket and then
turn a bit up okay i could turn it a bit higher Hello!
Hello!
Okay, wait.
Alright.
I turned it a bit higher.
Guys.
We're running a place so we can add you the umar post.
Wait, I got something even better.
Let me get rid of the hongbao.
Let me get rid of my licey phone.
Real quick.
Alright, I'll give you guys something even better.
Watch this.
Uh...
Where is it?
I where did I download this is this oh wait that's not not
was this but no no then a touch oh wait no not this one
that's not the right one is this oh gnarly that's right
chicken wings gnarly I don't remember I remember the lyrics
it's just all so like Tesla gnarly
all right is it if I see me is this I'm trying to remember
where it is this this is very important the one I'm trying
to find is very very important oh this one
Bump, bump, bump, bop, bump.
Nah, nah, nah, nah, non, nah, nah, no, nah.
Bump, bana, nah, no, no, no, no.
I don't know.
Bump, bumb, bump.
Wait, okay, I have other stuff, too.
I don't remember all the stuff I downloaded, was this.
Oh, man.
I don't even know what dance this is.
I really forgot.
I forgot everything I downloaded.
Wait, what about this?
What the?
Does anyone recognize this?
Because I don't, actually.
I actually don't recognize what this.
Look at this.
But break it down.
That's right.
I'm breaking it down.
I don't remember what this dance is.
I'm bogeying.
I'm bogeying right now.
I'm bogey so hard.
I'm singing a song.
What song am I...
Oh, oh, it's... Touch, touch.
Oh, it's... It's the... It's one of those K-pop songs.
It's... Oh, it's... It's... Say So.
I'm super shy, super shy, super shy, super shy, that one,
sorry, it was one of them, I couldn't remember, it was two,
how was this, super shy, super shy, super shy, oh, and then
there's a classic don't worry i got you guys oh this one is
nothing i got you guys look at this this is for all you guys
over there if it works guys it doesn't work guys i broke it
um guys guys i might have accidentally broke oh there we go
there we go watch this this one is a classic okay it's
getting where's the classic part don't worry don't worry
you're gonna we're getting there don't worry right here
we're gonna um you're getting there you guys are gonna
figure out what it is we're almost there we're almost there
just let me dance a little bit we're almost there
yeah yeah no it's not the macarita you're gonna be you're
gonna feel so silly when i do the actual move you're gonna
feel so silly because you couldn't guess it
that's right don't you feel so silly now go i can i can
definitely do that wait let me i just face the screen.
Give me a sec.
There you go.
Front facing dokey.
Oh, what the?
Why is it?
What's wrong with this hand?
Oh my god.
Why is it backwards?
That's why you feel silly now.
Okay, I gotta reset myself real quick.
guys give me a sec oh my god I have to really fully reset
myself I gotta reset myself give me a sec I'm resetting and
pause pause pause we're almost done yeah oh whatever they're
like they're like you sort of messed up and i'm like that's
all right oh what the that's not where i am where the how do
i oh where did i go oh hey that's my is that my feet
why am i backwards oh that's not good all right where where
i go there I am it's okay I'm right here guys I'm right here
everything is okay wait how about we oh shit too too close
too close we got all right to a little too close buddy try
to remember how to do this whoa hello okay wait wait well
rotating dokey whoa
all right let me fix this i need where am i hey all right
zero zero zero zero zero what the fuck why is everything up
here by my zero whoa i'm trying to reset everything why am i
up here oh is it one one one one one one one there you go
it's one it was one guys it was actually one hold mouse
button to pan is pan this oh okay i'm just gonna do free
look at this yay look at that new toy new toy
um alan think of the super chat think of Thank you.
Now dance without the emotes, IRL dancing.
Yeah, I can do that.
Watch this.
This is all real, by the way.
I gotta, like, prepare myself real quick.
Guys, holy shit.
Okay.
I gotta, like, warm up real quick.
You guys want me to do an actual, um, an actual, uh, thing.
Okay, watch this, guys.
It's gonna be so, you're gonna, it's gonna be so cool.
Watch this.
Three, two, one.
Boom!
back flip wow oh no that was pretty that was pretty intense
wasn't it whoa it's so real
you want to see that again i know you do watch this oh my
god you're gonna watch this guys all right i'm gonna do a
cartwheel into a flip all right in three two one cartwheel
backflip boom you want to see that again cartwheel front
foot oh yeah oh my god oh that was i'm so tired from that i
gotta sit down actually oh my god i got oh that was so much
work oh my god holy fuck I'm oh my god I'm so tired I got
guys I oh my god that oh that was so much energy that I used
just now oh my god I gotta relax a little after that all
right wait oh my mic is still peaking okay I'll fix it don't
worry I'll fix it filter compressor okay threshold uh 35 all
right sound yeah let me know if it's better now okay wait
you guys watch this did it work
i don't even know but i don't know
you sound you sound lower now so quiet oh oh let me turn it
up more hello hello hello well sound guy wanted 35 it sounds
a lot quieter now all right let me sound guy fix it i up
myself high hello hello you were good before all right then
let's do it from before sound guy fix this oh shit sorry i
hit i hit my mic sorry it's so weird it's so weird having a
wireless mic i'm um i'm not used to it i hit my i hit it's a
headset mic so i hit it that's like don't make me don't make
me hit you
why am i like so far away guys let me oh it's because i am
far away i was like wow i'm so far away there you go there
we go yeah that's right i'm having fun
the sound guy you've been still here hello sound guy are you
around wait let's go back we're going to go back now no more
purple screen back here that's right but actually if i'm
sitting down i should be here that's oh my gosh way i can
fix this um wait where is it all right i'll make it more
immersive
wait actually um since i'm sitting down
there you go yeah
yeah wow oh what's wrong oh i gotta recalibrate again okay
wait i can recalibrate this i can fix this and then there
you go all right wait let me uh this microphone do okay i
don't think i can return this at least i bought it like
today so so don't i can return this i can actually return
this okay i gotta let me fix this real quick this is
calibrated oh maybe it's my head all right let me all right
i am going to recalibrate recalibrate time all right all
right step forward I will return it I don't I spent too much
money I spent too much money oh my god where did I go why am
I here now over here what the fuck okay wow zoom in zoom out
there you go I was like how did I get there crazy yay what
happened to my hand I went out of bounds all right sound
guys looking into it I zoomed I did wait where's my my hand
is not doing so well though it really ain't what hat is this
okay it's this hat why is it like that wait what if I swap
it I'm gonna rotate this oh yeah I'm gonna rotate my hand
you heard that click that was my hand okay wait I'm gonna
just put it this way maybe that'll rotate better don't wait
I have I don't have health insurance it's
it's okay it's okay i don't have health insurance it's okay
um everything will be fine i'll put it at this hello okay
but you guys can hear me now right i broke my body or
yeah is my audio okay now
yeah okay i was just worried i'm like too quiet or something
but now okay oh yeah okay wait there's some other subquests
oh my gosh i don't know what to do with this hand this this
um i think i love canadian health care this is okay though
this hat is okay this one um oh
okay wait i have some let me a new toy let me show you more
of my new toy guys uh
i need your manager to hold your channel hostage until you
renew your health insurance card thank you for the super
chat nexi thank you thank you all right check this out where
is it
okay but not that oh my god i sorry my eyes went like crazy
there like this is my favorite though you guys saw this all
of this already but wait actually Oh my god, no, that's not
good
Holy my eye bags flew away
I read it wrong Whoa, my eye bags are so tired It's floating
away I want to show you Wait, that's not the right one
that's right I got a gun pew pew bam that's right yippee-kai
yay I got a gun wait wait wait and then bum bum bum bum bum
and then wait is this my right hand no that's not that's my
left.
All right.
Hand over the licey.
Hand over the homebound.
No one gets hurt.
That's right.
Hand over the red pocket.
Ma'am.
Or sir.
That's right.
Oh, I'm aiming for the roof.
I'm aiming at you, chat.
The hand over the light seed I got red pockets now or else
what or else you get or else chat gets it that's right BAM
BAM hold it up thank you the super chat thank you thank you
hands up suddenly fire on
She says, threateningly, I know my rights.
I know you're married.
So hands up.
And give me that red pocket.
Whoa.
I'm having too much fun it's oh oh yeah yeah wait wait wait
let me show you guys something pretty neat we have to go
here Kaysen thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
what you say sorry i can't read i'm it.
What does this say?
Pronounce.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Never get married.
Exactly.
Pro tip, if you want passive income, never get married.
You'll always get passive income.
every year every year I saw a tweet where someone's mom gave
them red pockets it was like please get married soon I don't
want to keep giving you like please get married soon I want
to stop giving you red pockets that's that's fuck that's
actually fuck all right let me show you guys something cool
new toy I love my new toy all right i'll unarm myself real
quick now wherever it is so do you don't you hate it when
you don't know where to put your gun all right watch this um
bomb bomb bomb wait where is it all right oh oh okay this
looks a little awkward you guys might be like what the fuck
is that but
we're in the saloon yeah okay we're in the saloon guys we
gotta figure out how to move here look oh my god my hand is
not okay maybe I'll fix it let me fix my hand I don't think
my hand's okay all right i'm fixing it i just want to fix my
hand bump bump am i fixed now
i'm fixed i just can't oh yay wait i can't i'm technically
fixed all right look is this a new it's you Hey guys.
DK, thank you for the awkward Hey Fajor.
Thank you for the awkward super.
Thank you.
I was married once.
So here, take my money.
Happy New Year.
Thank you.
Thank you for the awkward super.
Alright.
I might can move to the bar.
Okay, wait.
Whoa.
whoa how do I move to the bar you don't know if I'll just
wait I can technically move myself give me a sec I'll figure
this out well that's bomb bomb are you not immersed right
now okay well I'm inside the stool but wait oh shit my leg
my leg came out i need to fix that all right wait okay
immersion look at that and that's what you call immersion oh
oh dope dope
That's what you call Immersion
There you go Are you not immersed?
Oh my god Oh my god that both my Oh no Are you not immersed
I think I might need hand trackers.
I think I might need to grab hand trackers.
I knew I forgot something I got all oh, did you guys see the
um, did you guys see the new like viral tweet about like
body track like Like 3d tracking about actually wearing
anything that shit looks cool.
I think I might look into that I mean like you know what's
crazy.
It's cheaper than it's
That's for sure
It's cheaper than dokeelan like Yeah, yeah, and it has it
comes with hand tracking which is great.
That's what I need
Yeah, no, I really like get it for 7k Because my manager was
in talks with the people just to see I want to do a trial
run on it though I'm not sure if I actually I'm not sure yet
because like it's you know 3d is always improving and
everything um but i can get like a discount on it because my
manager was talking to the people uh uh yeah um and oh yeah
other than that i had a great lunar new year how about you
guys i made nigo i keep saying it the man you're in with but
um i had a great start of the lunar new year i want to be
closer actually give me a sec let's Let's be more personal
here.
Let's put that.
Oh, whoa.
Why?
Whoa.
Camera's so confused.
Okay.
Let's not do that.
The camera was like, where is Doki brain?
We'll do it here.
The camera couldn't find me.
Oh, my gosh.
Let's fix this.
I was like, I did a thing where it like follows you, but the
camera's like, where is she?
I didn't know where I was, which is, which was a little
scary.
Oh my god, wait, I don't know my perspective, apparently.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Alright, I don't know my deaf perception here.
all right there you go all right
oh yeah I fucked up my tradition you're supposed to not wash
your hair during um during lunar new year and then on the
first day I washed I washed I went took a shower I already
fucked up I messed it up no I was so I felt I felt
disgusting um Yeah, because the thing about that is that,
oh, you see this, this is me like leaning on my, oh my gosh,
I wish I could have better.
This is me like putting my hand on my face right now.
But tradition-wise, it's bad luck to take a shower during
Lunar New Year, because on the start of Lunar New Year is
where all your luck comes in.
And if you take a shower during Lunar New Year, you're
washing away all the luck you just earned.
So that's why it's like super bad luck.
And I did on the first day.
because I was like, I forgot to take a shower the day before
it.
I was like, I feel disgusting.
And I had to go out too, because I wanted to, I wanted to go
out to celebrate Lunar New Year, and then so I was just
like, alright, I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I type don't feel, I
felt like disgusting, and I was just like, fuck it, alright.
It's over.
It's over for me.
Are y'all the luck guy?
God ever I hit my mic I got so like I got Too into it and I
hit my mic Oh hey guys It looks like it when I lean in a
little closer
It's over Wait let me second I'm gonna put my My feet on the
desk Oh
Wait I don't go back up Why don't I go back up
where's Matt where's the rest of me help I'm stuck help me
I'm stuck on the floor I gotta do my calibration again
calibration oh oh I'm okay now I'm Oh, there we go.
Alright, let me sit back down.
Oh, my god.
Now I have to do this all over again.
Oh, hey, but my hands are better now.
It's the little things, guys.
It's the little things in there.
Okay, and then...
Let me make it so I sit.
Actually...
Boop.
there you go yay
all right that's fine oh i'm like blocking him okay wait
that's you guys all right oh shit there you go there you go
yay yeah so um so but i had fun i had i'd really needed it
you know like i really needed like those two days to like
just go out and like just enjoy touching grass i was so out
of it i just need you guys to know i i was so out of it
after like uh the pubg tournament like i felt like i had did
i i was just doing so many things i know which way i want to
fix i don't know where i put my camera here oh but then i
could talk to you guys like this hey oh oh but i'm like not
really on the chair no more where's the camera there's the
camera there you go yeah i really needed to unwind there um
but i still wanted to do a lunar new year stream for you
guys because like the best thing about lunar new year is
that it's like you know it's last like I saw two weeks left
to do a Lunar New Year stream and yeah, I thought, you know,
I play around with some new things, you know.
Dad was the experiment and I was just like, ooh, ooh, I get
to do more fun things with this, you know?
Play around with this a little bit more.
But yeah, no, I already fucked up the tradition, like, you
know, the number one, not the number one rule, but one of
the rules is like, don't take a shower.
I'm gonna take a shower so anyway I guess I lost all my luck
but I did eat nigo and I love me if you guys ever had like
sweet rice cake it's so good like the traditional sweet rice
cake I always do it usually you're supposed to eat it with
just like you just you just like uh fry it up or just like
cut it or something and heat it up um and uh and uh I like
to pan fry it with because it's so good it's like if you
never tried sweet rice cake with egg it's so fucking good
it's all like um this is the one is my go-to way of eating
it um yeah they fucking slap yeah I was on a paper plate
because I was too lazy to do dishes I was just like bro I
literally touch grass I don't want to do dishes I literally
I spent my entire day like outside I don't want I don't want
to fucking do my dishes I'm tired guys I'm so tired as per
tradition it was on a paper plate get no I will never get
rid of the paper plates they are very convenient after I'm
done I just throw it way i already have to wash the pan
there's less dishes to wash chat it's just less dishes to
wash and it's just convenient it's all about convenience
guys also i hope the mute bgm has not been too loud because
i've been playing around with um i've been playing around
with my i'm gonna return this wireless mic because
apparently it's bad i maybe i should have asked the sound
team about suggestions instead of my friends
You're just, what do you mean I'm so lazy?
I, okay, I didn't do all, I set all of this up.
It's been an entire month of events.
So what do you mean?
I'm just lazy IRL.
Like I, you know how it's like you can only choose one or
the other?
You know, you know how it's like you choose one or you be
productive, have good sleep or have good growth.
You know, like have good grades, be active, or have good
sleep, and you can only choose two.
Well, for me, um, it's either I get my life together, or I
feed my dragoons.
Do you guys want to starve?
You literally had an entire month of events.
But others are you choose two.
Mine is you choose one.
Um, to get it.
Yeah, you want me to starve you
Yay starving
Yeah, but but um oh wait Sorry, I just like looking at this.
Whoa, see that who's married Guilty for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um Suddenly if I lost um, I can't really this part and lay
something something will home or home bow shit yeah thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you something
something home bow and then you said thank you you want me
to a functioning adult in society you're asking too much
right now you are asking too much I wish I could point at
you I it's like I got like Botox on my hand I wish I wish I
could point at right now i just i knew i forgot something um
i don't even know if i want to buy hand trackers just to do
it just to be able to point at you um next seat they give us
a super how much are hand trackers i'm gonna look that up
hand trackers how um what are they called the hand tracker
shit like i remember what they're called the ones for like
oh there it go shit okay there's a budget one there's a
budget one but again that i'm just i rather just grab the
fucking the the no no oh yeah apparently um yeah they're
they're pretty expensive there there is webcam tracking but
i don't like plugging my web i don't want to plug in my
webcam the government's gonna see me i might as well put on
my tinfoil hat i don't like i don't like I don't want
plug-in my webcam.
I don't want I don't want my FBI agent to look at me Makes
sense They can look at me through my phone.
I just don't want them to look at me through my webcam, you
know
Fair Hello, mr.
FBI agent The phone I better angles on the phone not on the
webcam So I don't want them to look at me through If they
want to look at me I better I know my angles on the phone
Not on the webcam
Please read me a bit Yeah it's all about the angle Exactly
Yeah You know like You know like For those who own laptops I
was one of those people that put like a Put a sticky note on
the webcam Yeah that's right i ain't taking my chances
if my fbi agent is looking at me through my webcam i don't
trust them they have other ways to look at me same to be
honest no it's because my school gave us laptops well we
paid for them technically it was part of our tuition um
because i went to international school so um wait let me i
feel weird like looking there you go it's like i'm looking
at you guys now um so um so my school um at before it was it
was so fucked up so like um um my school we our tuition
includes like laptops and stuff so uh we each get our own
laptop for school and then is so fucked up because like the
year after the grade before us got apple got got apple max
by paying the same tuition our laptops were del and then
they got max and at that time max was like super popular
back then so then like obviously like you max but back then
it was like there were more people were using max than um
dels and also i got a del so and then we were so they had a
apple party too that was the worst part because they're like
the the grade below us like you know like that year after we
just kept our lap we like you're like oh when you're at this
I think it was like I think it was sixth grade when you hit
sixth grade um when you hit sixth grade you get like a
laptop that's part of your tuition and then when the new
sixth grade class came in they got Macs MacBooks and then
they literally held an apple party for them they had like a
little like celebration for the the new sixth graders be
like yay you guys got macbooks yeah
when they gave us they're just like here's your your shitty
Dell laptops and we're like okay and then for them they got
like a little fucking pizza party yeah fucking and you know
what's worse I swear I thought this was a conspiracy because
God was there that was like the principal's daughter was a
grade below us and then you know when she hit sixth grade
what a coincidence she got a MacBook like what a fucking
coincidence like wow she hit sixth grade and then somehow
they changed the process where now you all get MacBooks
instead
right um i forgot where the story was gonna go oh yeah yeah
but yeah when i got left i would just put like a little
sticky note tape i think i told the story before since we're
talking about the laptop thing actually broke the screen
because uh in sixth grade uh we were not allowed to bring
our laptops home until um seventh grade or i think eighth
grade i think it was like either eighth grade we were
allowed to bring our laptops home by the way like the laptop
supposed to last us all the way to high school um like end
of like end of the year so like they don't give us new
laptops by the way this laptop was last us all the way till
we graduate in high school so um um but on sixth grade to
seventh grade we were not allowed to bring the laptops home
we had to put in this little cubby and then um and um
technically um we share it with our part where we actually
shared this laptop um with someone else technically i think
oh yeah i remember oh sorry i remember sixth grade uh for us
we had to share lap our laptops with someone else until
seventh grade where we got like each we get our own laptop
like you're like oh here's your own laptop so like in sixth
grade we share it by the way the new sixth graders they get
to keep their macbooks so that's why we're like wow they get
to keep they don't have to share their macbooks and they get
anyway so in sixth grade I remember this um um basically oh
wait sorry yeah sixth grade when we're sharing our laptops
and stuff um um with like uh with like a partner from the
other class like we were all in sixth grade um because they
were split into two classes and um I actually broke my
screen because I like had something when I was closing my
laptop screen um I actually something in the screen so when
I was pushing it down the screen cracked and then you know
you would like you know the same thing to do is to tell the
teacher being like I actually broke the glass but then I
didn't want my parents to pay for it the rational idea of
being like oh I'm sorry I broke actually it was an accident
so what I did instead was I broke the glass I closed that I
I closed the lid back and then I just put it in the shelf
and then I left and then the next day I got called in by the
the the technology teacher or like the I don't know what
they're called the computer science teacher or whatever and
the tech support teacher and then she was like what had like
pulled me and my my other my partner the the person I shared
my laptop with and they're like, I was like, oh, what
happened?
You know, I got called, obviously I knew what happened.
Like, I got called in with my partner.
I was like, what happened?
And like, what happened?
Like, why, what's going on?
And they're like, oh, he's like, did you know what happened
to our laptop?
The screen's cracked.
I was like, what?
The screen was okay when I last saw it, put it there.
Are you sure?
Like, are you sure it wasn't you?
They're like, no, I went to grab it for this morning and it
was cracked.
Who broke our laptop?
I didn't want to get in trouble.
I, you know, how did that happen?
Like, I didn't want to get in trouble, okay?
I didn't want my parents to pay for it and I didn't get in
trouble.
Anyway, and then, and then, um, like, no way.
And then they're like, like she interrogated each of us
individually to figure out who was the one that was lying.
Was it me or him?
And then they're like, what happened?
And I was like, oh, I was just working on, I was working on
my classwork for science.
And then after, you know, after science class was done, I
just put the laptop back in the cubby and then I left, I
went home.
And she's like, hmm, I see.
to my parents like do you know what happened like what
what's going on she's like yeah like just asked me i went to
grab it this morning and the screen's all broken and then
she called both of us back and like well i don't know what
happened but we're gonna get the screen replaced um but
please don't let this happen again um if you know what like
please don't let this happen again and now she's like oh
yeah like i wish i knew what happened like i wish i knew who
did this like
with it that's right got the perfect crime and I got away
never caught the perfect crime never punished you did the
cute act that you always do didn't you yeah but thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you that's right The
Statue of Limitations ran out.
She can't get me now.
I was called her a bitch.
I mean, she was a pretty...
I really did not like her.
I also did not like the technology teacher, the computer
science.
She was such a bitch.
Never caught.
That's right.
Easiest heist of all my time.
The one who got it.
way she was terrible i hated her i i don't remember why i
hated her but the feeling was still there i is rubber i did
not like her and i don't remember why i hated her but the
hate is still there in my heart i might not remember why i
hated her but it's the the hate transcends the memory um oh
yeah i was gonna say oh yeah uh oh bring the background
music oh was the background music throughout it all right I
brought the BGM down a little bit there's always I have
several teachers that made me angry um there was there's
other teacher that I hated he was a PE teacher I hated him
so much so basically let me be a little closer I hated him a
lot because basically he took PE super fucking serious And
then he became the director of physical ed.
He became the director of our sports program and also
physical education.
And I hated him because he would make us write essays and
stuff.
He would make us feel like a questionnaire slash mini essay
every week.
At the end of the week where we have to be like, what are
your goals?
Like, what are your goals?
What are your plans for this week of physical education?
do to be um to like in like uh to achieve your goals for
this week for pe yeah no it's crazy it was like 10 questions
and you have to write like like a paragraph for each
question and we have to do it for every week and i everyone
fucking hated because it's like pe like you know we're not
using our brains for fucking pe like we're here to like
sweat it out like i told this story before for those who are
new and never heard of the story before um basically um um i
got called out during like his mini rant that he was doing
to his class uh during the class because like um you know i
was really i i was very athletic athletic back then and now
i'm just a vtuber so i just stay at home all the time and i
get tired after going out for like one day up but basically
I got called out during his little mini rant about like
grades because it was mid report card season and a lot of
the students who were on the pathway to the honors to honors
had to like go talk to him personally and being like can you
please change my grade and stuff because I really want
because like it's really fucked up but the only way only
thing that was blocking people from getting honors PE
because he was such a harsh grader in PE.
So the girls who are not good at PE were getting B's and
stuff because they write really good essays, but they're
just not physical in the physical education part.
So they would go to his office hours to like beg him to like
fix their grades because literally PE was denying them
honors the honors class like the getting into the honor
society um and getting recognized to be in the honors
program and um and then during PE class he was talking about
him being like I'm grading very fairly you know like I can
see if you're you know it's not if you're not you're not
good at PE like that's fine but I need to see you try you're
you're being graded like this and then he's like look at
doki over there you know you can see she actually trying in
pe but she doesn't she doesn't do well in the um in the
right written portion of it like i would have given her an a
but she's not doing well and she doesn't um uh she doesn't
like excel in the written portion in physical edging in pe
and that's why i give her a b plus and i'm like bro what the
fuck like
I was just like what what the fuck like you could I I
wouldn't even go to your office hours to complain I didn't
like I didn't fucking care like I got b plus I don't fucking
care like um and so like I got called out because they're
like yeah she should get an a if we're a if we're like we're
focusing on the physical part of physical education but she
didn't enough effort in a written portion.
Now, fucking course I didn't put enough effort.
It's PE.
I'm gonna try to focus on English, English humanities,
science, and math.
Like, if I have to write, I'm gonna write in humanities.
Like, I'm not gonna fucking write in PE.
I don't care.
I read, like, one or two sentences.
I'm done.
Like,
yeah.
So I was just like, bro, fuck that.
shit like like I didn't use my brain for the actual written
portions that matter I just show up to PE like I clock in
and I clock out yeah like I'm here the min max bro I'm
fucking min maxing right now um who has a bro that's why I
hated this p teacher so much i hated him and he was and then
he got promoted he got like everyone hated him like every
grade hated this guy and then he got promoted and then he
got promoted to director of the athletic program like the
all the sport teams and stuff and everyone was like why like
what the fuck we all hate him and then he let when he got
when he got when he got transferred to a like celebrate we
threw a party that's how like all the parents hated him too
like that's the thing because like all the parents hated him
because he his class his PE was always the class that was
cucking students from the honors like from getting honors
like and the parents would go to his office hours to try to
make him change his grade and he would be put his foot down
be like it's not my fault your your your daughter slash son
just didn't put enough effort in PE like uh and you know i
was like the first one to find that fight look i wasn't
first i was the second one to find out he got trapped he was
leaving our school and got transferred to um he got
transferred to a different country in different country
slash international school because i was friends with some
of the parents i think it was like yeah it was during soccer
like during soccer season and we're traveling to like the
city uh for the tournament like um for the end of the year
we're trying I don't forgot it was what country or city we
were in because it was an international tournament and I was
like hanging out with like one of the parent that our
parents chaperones there who was also the coach of the one
the soccer who was one of the assistant coaches for the
soccer team and then she was like oh you know about I'm not
gonna say his name I'm not gonna dox him but fuck you bro I
still hate you uh I'll I'll I'll give him a name his name is
not green yeah you're like oh you heard about mr green and i
was like i'm like oh yeah i hate him and he's she's like
yeah everyone hates him but he's getting transferred to
mumbai um he's leaving our school and going to mumbai and i
was like oh i was like no and she's like yeah he's heading
over to mumbai now like next year i'm like no i'm
like oh my god um yeah and then and then and then literally
after that conversation I like I like went straight to the
girls I'm like girls girls mr.
green is leaving he's gonna go to Mumbai we're like yeah
they're like we're like celebrating like oh my god the witch
is dead that's like you guys he's living
We were so happy.
We were so fucking happy.
I was like, girls, great news!
He's going to Mumbai!
7-5, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Happy Lunar New Year, Sun Deng, Sun Deng, thank you, thank
you, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I was just, I was so happy.
Oh my god, no, fuck that guy.
him as a teacher oh my god he was a terrible fucking teacher
nobody liked him no one
oh my god i'm glad it was i'm glad it was over with that guy
he was the worst everyone counted the days where he left
when he finally left um no no no no the replacement was
better we had a good replacement he was just a terrible PE
teacher and a terrible person like it was fucked up because
we had like girls coming to his office hours literally
crying because they were like please this is the only class
I gotta be in like they were literally crying be like please
is there anything I can do to like because they're like not
that great at PE but like you know like that's not on them
that they're like they they're selling the written portion
but it's not on them that they're like they're not like as
athletic as the other students so like and they were like
crying being like coming to like it was during like recess
or what like reading break um and we would just be in the
library because his office his office was near the library
and then like i would see like girls coming out of his
office hours literally cry like just crying and stuff
because he won't change their grades or like give them an
opportunity like let them do extra credit to like um let
them have like get an a or some shit yeah yeah that's why
like i fucking hated him like everyone hated him i was like
that's just so messed up like like it's like it's not their
fault it's not their fault they're not like as of like
they're not as athletic as the other students like like
they're trying their best but they're like he was like i
could tell when you are trying your best and like from what
i see you are not trying your best so you get a beat like
Yeah, let me recalibrate real quick.
This is the only issue I have with this is that you gotta
recalibrate very often.
if I, because like, it's like moving around the trackers and
everything, so I have to recalibrate it often.
I just don't understand how...
Oh, I stepped too fast.
I just don't understand how, like, he got fucking promoted.
Alright.
Let's see if this works.
Nah, they're like, it can be improved.
I'm like, good enough.
Good enough.
Yeah, I'm having a lot of fun.
I hope you guys had a good Lunar New Year.
What do you guys do for Lunar New Year?
Bum, bum, bum.
it's so cool to be able to move around and like i don't have
to speak in front of my mic i can just like um move my body
around nothing much i grinded 17 hours of eight i i realized
i forgot to unlock my own skin so i was playing apex a
little early bro my first game of apex oh my god like i
literally obviously haven't played in a while and then like
i've had my pred badge on at the top but then like pred
bronze bronze like you know like the meme format and i
literally um i was literally just like it was literally my
first game and i was so tired too because i've been working
all day like today this to like today when i wake up to now
and then the guy when we both died he was like how are you
pred and don't 1k damage yet i'm like shut the fuck up bro
do you do you have a skin in apex i don't think so oh my god
how many how many times you spend your time playing this
game epics i was like shut the fuck up do you not see the
animated bronze badges bro like bro you know what's even
worse we're playing wild card like we weren't even playing
rank we weren't playing pubs it was fucking wild card like
um everyone was playing wild card is like um who's playing
here to grind the points to unlock shit.
Bro, why are you taking this shit so seriously?
We're not even in rank, bro.
And you still complain.
I know.
I was like, bro, why are you complaining in wild card of all
game modes?
What the fuck?
God damn, log off.
Like, like, like, like, like, like, like, log off.
like bro i'm trying to do my pk challenge right now why do
you think i don't have one k damage yet
it's not even rank bro like chill
yeah no that was really um that was really like today like
two hours before my stream because i wanted i was like shit
i should i doubt i guys it might be a little embarrassing I
don't know if I'll have my Watson skin by tomorrow.
By the way, there's members Apex Custom Lobby tomorrow to
celebrate my skin.
But then I forgot, I've been so busy that I forgot to grind
for it.
So I'm only at 2,000 points.
Guys, can I make it by tomorrow?
I already did all the daily.
Guys, will I be able to make it?
I only have 2,000 points.
Guys, I just need 2,000 more.
I just need 2,000 more.
No!
So most likely, I might not make it.
I might not make it with the, um, in the, by then.
I literally need, like, two more days.
I forgot.
I grinded today, and then, like, the, you know, the one I
did on Twitch stream.
um howard thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
um suddenly five law uh cheers to prosperous year of endless
wealth and endless smiles hope doki and all dragons have
wonderful lunar new year with their loved ones um uh thank
you for the super chat howard thank you thank you thank you
i really appreciate it yeah well you can't get points in
custom matches i just want to around that's all that's
really it that's that's one of the reasons um i just wanted
to see all the dokees running around in the lobby that's why
um oh yeah what else do i want to talk to you guys about i
wrote like a bunch of stuff i wanted to like oh let me i've
been so busy i can't wait for I'm just been like all over
the place the last last month since December since December
with Dokilan it's been like gas gas gas gas and I'm so tired
now I'm so fucking tired but I still hope you guys had you
know cute little stream idea you know celebrating with you
guys here I get to move myself too like look at that and I
get to walk away but you guys can still hear me talk with my
oh my god hey oh my god hey guys hey dragon what do you want
what do you i can't see chat right now but what do you want
today hmm where are you looking to drink for huh we have i
don't remember what's on the menu and i can but don't worry
i can mix anything oh but show me your id though i didn't
know you're legal Because, like, you're, I don't know, man.
You're an egg.
Unless you've been in that egg for 18 years.
I don't know.
Show me that ID.
You got a soda.
No soda here.
All alcohol.
All right, wait.
When was I?
Oh, yeah, I wanted to.
I, like, wrote some stuff down.
All the stuff I want to talk about.
Um.
let's see what
is it oh my god bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum oh my
god I forgot to tell you guys about this I went and I got
invited to a Galantimes I got invited to do like a
Galantimes meetup with with two of uh with one of my friends
and she invited me i like she invited me to uh to like hang
out with her friends and then i forgot to tell the story but
thing is i was literally doing my laundry on that day
galantimes that's what you that's like it's like on the 13th
so like you celebrate with a bunch of other female friends
um and one of my well i only have one friend in my
I only have one of my friends my only friend that lives in
my city invited me to her to celebrate with her friends um
because she's like it's so sad that you're alone um so
she didn't say that and she didn't say that but that's what
I interpreted she's like oh man so sad that she's all alone
Anyway, anyway, so the funny thing is like, obviously, like,
you know, I didn't think I was going to be going out,
especially, like, you know, I was like, 13th, there's
nothing really special on the 13th, you know, and so, like,
I was doing my laundry, and then literally, I only had one
clean shirt, and then the only clean shirt I had was, it was
a meow shirt, it was like this, okay, let me say I could
find the shirt, and I'll show it to you guys, but it was
like this meow shirt, like a face of meow, and then the text
said, I want money.
I was like, that's the only shirt I had, the only clean
shirt I had because I was doing laundry.
It's like, I want money.
And then it was a face of me out.
And I like literally wore that to meet her friends.
And I was like, I'm sorry.
I didn't, I was trying, I was doing my laundry.
It's so sad you're alone here.
I have a pity Super Gus, thank you, with a Super Chat, thank
you, thank you, yeah, that's, that's a dokey shirt, wait,
let me take it fine, it's such a cute shirt, I actually love
that shirt, I think I bought that shirt in New York when I,
uh, when I like, uh, when I like, uh, at, when I went to
that convention, Anime New York, New York, I think that was
what it was.
all right uh i want money meow shirt oh there it is yeah
meow yeah that's the exact shirt i wore i found it so easy
this is the exact shirt i wore to hate to meet her friends i
i was like i just like just doing laundry i didn't think i
was gonna go anywhere i think i was gonna hang out with
anyone.
This is literally the shirt I wore.
Like everyone was dressed up and everything and like did
makeup and stuff.
Cause I was like, I'm not, I know.
Was like dressing up really nice and like wearing makeup and
everything.
And then I literally showed up with this shirt.
For those, wait.
I literally showed up with this shirt.
Because I was like, bro, I'm not putting makeup on.
I'm wearing this fucking shirt.
Like, it's literally the only clean clothes I have.
It's literally doing laundry.
I want money.
I mean it does fit me it's such a good shirt I love it I
fucking love this shirt so much it is a good shirt I agree
this person makes a lot of good shirts I also have this one
um I have this one I love her stuff this they're all so cute
let me say I couldn't save it this is the other shirt that I
bought from them no spice no life no spice no life is there
anything else I remember I bought that buy another shirt was
that it oh wait they had wait no they had a side no they had
another shirt they had another really good shirt wait let me
see I could Let me see if they're still selling it.
There's this other shirt that I have from them.
I remember now.
They don't sell it anymore!
Really?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh my,
okay.
Let me see if I can find it.
Um...
I remember what it was.
Uh, shirt.
They are some nice shirts.
They are.
This one.
This is the other shirt that I have
It's a combo I have both of them It's like how I feel that
day, you know It's like how do I feel today Do I feel like
I'm do I feel like thoughts or no thoughts?
What is what am I feeling today?
This shit I can't These shirts, I don't, they're so good, I
fucking love my, I love these shirts.
Oh, it's from a different, this is from a different creator.
I lose track, I buy a lot of, like, clothes from people,
from, um, in, like, I guess, like, small, like, small
businesses.
This one's one of my favorite shirts.
It's like, am I having a breakdown right now?
I know we're thinking every single interactions I'm having.
Well, thought shirts it is for today.
Real.
But yeah, this one's my...
I love this.
You know what?
Let me see if I can...
Hey.
Money!
yeah free advertising it's a good shirt i'm i'm not
sponsored it's a good ass shirt it's a very good shirt i
like it oh yeah i should actually show a real thing by the
way um i almost forgot um i should actually show a real
thing that we have in the merch store right now if you guys
didn't know we just released our lunar new year uh
collection well it's not really voice pack actually maybe
the best way to say it's our lunar new year voice pack i
love the lunar new year alfanya show you guys the concept
but i forgot to tweet it out it's compelling me to do this
next thing thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
thank you music thank you the super chat thank you thank you
fine but only once thank you the super chat thank you thank
you all right Wait, I need to show you guys though.
I need to show you guys the actual, the outfit design.
It's one of my favorite, um, it's one of my favorite, uh,
voice pack outfits so far.
Uh, but yes, we have a limited edition button that you,
okay, wait, let's do the Will Smith me.
Wait.
Oh my god, it's so weird because it's mirrored.
Receive money, background, thank you for the super chat,
thank you, thank you, thank you.
Ta-da!
Oh, ta-da!
It's not mirrored, so it's like, like, it throws me off.
I mean, it is mirrored, so it throws me off a lot.
Let me grab it real quick.
Grab the concept art.
It just fucks me.
with my mind when it's like mirrored.
I'm not used to it.
My right hand is my left hand and I'm like that ain't right.
Oh yes, members, members, there is a special Lunar New Year
wallpaper that will be showing tomorrow.
So if you are a member, you will get a special Lunar New
Year wallpaper.
Members wallpaper.
It's by the same artist, but you get two wallpapers
technically.
where the fuck is the concept art give me a sec I'm trying
to find the concept art of this oh there it is
all right so this is the concept art of the lunar year
outfit it's pretty fire look I think it's one of my favorite
voice pack outfits so far.
Yeah!
So this is the outfit design for for the Lunar New Year
voice pack.
And I speak Cantonese in the voice pack too, by the way.
Little incentive, guys.
I mean, one more...
I know some of you guys are like, we need more Cantonese
doki.
I do speak Cantonese in the voice pack.
But this is the concept art for the voice pack.
It's one of my favorite outfits so far.
It looks so sick.
I just love everything about it, like the little patterns
and the bullet on the thigh and everything.
There's the gun.
My little purse to store my gun.
It's pretty good.
Oh yeah, this stream is not sponsored by PUBG.
I got...
I just realized I was playing.
I mean, like, the stream is not sponsored by PUBG, by the
way.
That's been over for a while now.
Let me fix that.
I forgot that was still going.
I didn't even notice it until now.
Let me fix that.
Alright.
Where's my timer?
No PUBG by the way.
Wait, everything else is turned off.
What the fuck?
There we go.
Have this other one.
Check out our...
shop store there you go i mean i'm doki merchant i've been
showing so many things yeah oh my gosh yeah woo yeah i'm in
the very chinese time of my life which is like my entire
life i'm chinese for those who don't know for those who
don't know every year is a very chinese time of my life
Woody's bald the new trailer dropped and he's fucking bald
he's balding not bald sorry he's he's middle-aged but I need
to show you guys this but yeah buy my merch by the way buy
my merch buy it it's limited it's limit well actually not
the voice pack the voice packs on the store forever there's
no FOMO for that but it's just the buttons it's the buttons
and also like the sell on other new year stuff yeah wait let
me show you guys because they're planning on making toy
story for five god i forgot it's at five now like it's at
five now but look at this he's look at him wait oh my look
at him he's balding he has a bald spot not my woody He's a
toy!
Why is he balding?
Why is he middle-aged?
Just let it, just shave it off.
Just shave it off.
There's no point.
I think it's like funny though that he's actually going...
Oh yeah, and also another news, another gaming news.
um apparently snake is at is in rainbow six siege now and
then i message min about it and then she was like no don't
do this to me and i literally was like you don't want to
play rainbow six siege i was like don't do it it's not worth
it and then and then i was like it's don't do it it's not
worth it and then she's like I'm so scared of being called 1
million slurs on my stream and I was like but that's the
siege experience oh yeah speaking of voice um speaking of
voice comms league is apparently testing out planning on
testing out bc comms voice chat in league uh for their next
like beta or some shit they're planning on testing it out
And I'm like, that is the biggest mistake they'll ever do.
Like, there's no way.
There's no way they should ever release voice chat for
League of Legends.
That shit.
You can't even say jump.
Apparently you can get, if you type it in text, if you type
jump in text, you can actually get warned.
so so it's like like how are you gonna monitor that shit
like text chat is already so fucking bad oh yeah and also by
the way for those who don't know um also uh overwatch is
also planning on giving you voice comms um which is crazy
over by the way for those who don't know um wait let me for
those For those who don't know, Oroosh is also planning on
adding voice comms at the end of the match.
And I'm like, that's definitely not going to go wrong, is
it?
Like, yeah, so they're planning on making it so at the end
of the match, you could talk to the enemy team.
And I can't wait for all the nice things they're going to
say to me at the end of the game.
Like, yeah.
very nice non-gamer stuff that's gonna happen in vc after
the end of the game yeah i was like bro why are all these
companies like dude do they not know what kind of audience
they have playing video games like bro we're all toxic
there's no hiding it what what is this revision of history
that we're trying to pull off like we're
um hey hey guys thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you everyone will be so nice to each other calling each
other regal nice gentleman and wish each other to keep
yourself safe thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you it's like everyone forgot everyone forgot about the
history of gaming uh what is it what's that saying go um
we're we're bound to repeat ourselves in history?
What is that famous saying, Go?
Guys, I'm pretty sure that is for data.
Oh my gosh, they're going to sell my voice to AI.
Was it bound to repeat itself?
What's that famous quote?
Yeah, history is doomed.
Is those who do not study history are doomed to repeat it.
yes that's it oh my god everyone all the streamers are gonna
have to turn off voice chat at the end of the game you can't
keep censoring it how is when we have bonds everyone's gonna
fucking everyone's gonna fucking turn off the voice chat for
the streamers it's already bad enough yeah
Turn that voice chat up.
Yeah.
YMCA.
My mic accidentally.
Bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada.
That's the macaroni.
Sure...
Let's see.
BOM A key.
Um, don't worry.
I don't have health insurance.
BOM BOM BOM BOM BOM BOM BOM BOM BOM BOM BOM Volume BOM BOMA
NOM BOM BOM BOM BOMB A NOM A MOM A MOM A.
BOM BOM BOM BOM BOM BOM BOM A MOM BOM BOM BOM A A MOM BOMB A
A MOM POM BOM ENA Oh my gosh, might No, I just need to
recalibrate Because I've been sitting down I can do that
Recalibrate Oh shit, not that Recalibrate
All right
it's cuz like um my trackers were falling off because I
because my clothes keep rubbing it oh I step forward too
fast damn it about recalibrate this again
recalibrating ah come on
recalibrate Yay!
Oh, hey, I'm here now.
Recalibrate.
Oh, wait, wait.
I could...
Oh my god, I'm more fluid now.
Wait.
It's actually good.
All right.
There you go.
All right, there you go.
.
And
Yeah, see I recalibrated it now.
Oh wait, we're okay now.
Oh my god, we're okay now.
Yay.
There you go.
Now we're more fluid.
Yay.
Yay!
No hospital visit.
Let's go!
Wait, I'm...
I'm trying to make sure my headphone doesn't fall off.
There you go.
Yeah, I don't have my tail to cut it off.
See?
No tail.
Bop, bop, bop, bop.
boop boop boop boop no tail they cut it off it's someone's
pink brush right now doing calligraphy I knew I forgot
something I forgot the tail yeah but look I'm so fluid it's
so cool moving around I just don't know what to do when I'm
moving around because I don't have hand trackers George they
give the super chat they Thank you.
I don't know how to pronounce that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm going to definitely make yin go later after the stream.
I'm craving it right now.
I'm hungry.
I finally, because I also went shopping.
I went shopping at my Asian supermarket.
And I was like, so I bought a lot of Asian food.
I bought a lot of dumplings.
I might make...
galsy later too because i bought a lot of dumplings and
stuff because dumplings are good luck for those who don't
know um dumplings you gotta eat dumplings you gotta eat
noodles you gotta eat uh tangerines uh you gotta eat rice
cake you gotta eat the um those are all good luck good
fortune and i bought uh galsy i bought dumplings uh at the
asian supermarket i also bought udon i've been craving udon
for so long i was like i want udon
I want Udo, and I pair it up with spam.
Yeah, Asian supermarket.
Let's go.
Yeah, and I bought myself Red Pockets, too.
And I don't know why.
I just thought it was pretty.
I was like, fuck it.
I just bought myself Red Pockets just for the sake of it.
Oh, yeah.
For those who are wondering, what am I planning on streaming
next week?
I don't know.
Next week, I'm just chilling.
No events.
Nothing special.
No surprises.
I just want to relax and then next month I'm really looking
for March March is my holiday I'm so look I'm gonna try I
want to stream at least once in March I'm gonna try and
stream like not March I'm not gonna be gone for the entire
March I meant I'll be gone for like one week in March but I
want to stream at least once during that one week um so it's
not like I fucking disappeared it's not like I got kidnapped
you're like you're gone I will be I don't worry I will It's
gonna be gone for like one week, but I'm looking forward to
that one-week vacation.
I fucking need it so much guys.
I really do.
I'm like so like I'm so tired I'm actually I'm so tired
I'm so tired.
Oh, that's so cute Yeah Oh my god, wait, that's cute.
Wait I'm just tired.
I deserve it.
I do.
I did so much stuff.
I just like hanging out with you guys too.
You know.
Wee.
Yeah.
Wow.
I'm just having fun playing around my new toy.
Wee.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, I saw the lion dance.
I forgot to talk about it.
You know, for those who don't know, the lion dance, the
whole purpose of the lion dances is that they chase away the
bad luck and bring in good luck to you and then the reason
why you have to feed them cabbages is that they're they're
giving they're eating the bad luck and spitting out the good
luck they're like yam yam yam yam yam and like good luck
it's really cool because there's like a specific there's
specific like um music to it it's like bum butter bum bum
bum bum bum bum bum bum and it's from your local martial
arts school it's fun yeah they rip up the bad luck and like
spit out the good that's the whole purpose of lion dance
yeah that's what the cabbage is for it's like um yeah it's
like yeah lettuce is uh it's like a play on words basically
they're birthing wealth and good luck to you so they're
giving you good fortune and good luck uh how should they
give welcome to the tomato farm welcome welcome but yeah i'm
i'm looking to making more mingau ming ming gau i always
ming gau it's such a weird word to say it's so weird to
pronounce you know like whenever i speak cantonese i feel
like i feel like toby fox when he's like toho project
that's how i feel when i speak whenever i mix cantonese and
english together But yeah, I'm looking forward to making
Mingo for it, like for myself.
Because I'm like, how do I, it just, it just feels so
awkward saying it, like, saying it, like, in the English
sentence.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
hun something something something guan i can't read i'm a
letter i'm too lazy to get up right now put it in translate
i i assume it's something lunar new year related so thank
you for the super chat cloud thank you someone translate i
can't read read in a fourth grade level.
That's all.
The mouse is so far.
This is where my mouse is.
Oh wait, I could sing the gong shi gong shi gong shi me.
Ah gong shi gong shi gong shi.
That's the only part I know from that song.
That's the only thing I know.
I don't know the rest of that song.
Yeah, because that song will play it.
We'll play all the time during Chinese banquets.
It's like the traditional.
It's like the traditional Lunar New Year song in general.
Oh my god.
Wait, I can sit cross-legged.
What?
That's so cool.
Oh yeah, I talked to the people, you know, the one that they
were the non the one camera with like you don't have to wear
any trackers Thing and they were saying that like it's not
ideal if you're sitting on the desk because Because it's
obviously like if it's not ideal you're sitting at a desk to
try to do 3d tracking I'm like, but that's all I do.
All I do is sit on the desk
could sit on the floor i don't want a game on the floor what
am i what am i gonna do
it's ideal and not toky proof so i use it i have to like
actually just move around and i'm like what do i do with 3d
yeah get 3d tracking just to sit that's right yeah but then
you can see me be expressive with my hands but i can't be
expressive because i don't have fingers my fingers don't
work what am i gonna do
i just want you guys to see how expressive i am but then my
fingers don't work no my gosh i can't i hate see okay let me
There you go.
Alright, let's see.
Hello.
Hello, I'm back.
I'm back from the floor.
My poor fingers.
That's a skill issue, I guess.
All I can do is just hold my red pocket.
That's all I can do.
Bye-bye.
other stuff that I want to tell you guys bomb bomb bomb oh
yeah I forgot about that wait I forgot I this word let's see
horse is that it what does it look like attached to my
Please
Fuck that looks so cursed.
Oh my god, it's coming out.
Oh my let the horse out
Wait, I can make it okay.
It's supposed to guys.
It's not supposed to look that bad It's supposed to be like
this
NAY!
That's like morph- what was it called?
The morph- the- the book where you're morphing into animals?
Morphable?
Oh my god I forgot what it's called.
You're the horse.
NAY!
80% head.
Yeah!
Animorphs, yeah!
Animals!
mores let the horse out
go let the beast out now that's right
by my final form the horse goes let me take off the hat new
hat goodbye goodbye hat oh wait I forgot wait I should be
able to use where is it Where's my favorite hat?
Where's my other favorite hat?
You know what I'm talking about, guys.
Wait.
There we go.
My other favorite hat.
Holy shit, that's too big.
Yay!
Toraymon!
Right?
Guys, it's Toraymon's hat.
has no other meaning mama says i'm special
i don't know
how the lyrics go again i like i said banana
i don't know how
the Cantonese version I just like draw a circle where was
the Cantonese version I want to look that up now Cantonese
Cantonese Cantonese opening
All right, let's see.
Cantonese opening Doraemon.
How does it go?
Oh, I have to put on my other headphones for that.
Well, I guess I'll never know.
I guess I'll never know.
I have to put on my other headphones for that.
I'm too lazy.
this headphone has fused into my has already fused into my
my head now there's no going back there's no going back this
is part of my body now oh yeah by the way i also have other
places we could go new toy i love my new toy all right where
is it oh did i not oh my I'm so fucking stupid.
I didn't even save it.
But I can do this.
Where did I put it?
Wait, where did I down?
Oh my god, it's all the way.
Oh my god, there's so many.
I don't know if this works.
Alright, let's see if this works, guys.
Alright, does it show up?
You know, I have to extract it.
God damn it.
Wait, is it?
not work
oh no there it is there it is all right where is this where
am i
yeah there's like a little stage look at that oh that's cute
it's like a little stage i should have been here the entire
time Wow, it's so festive.
It is!
It is festive.
We have another one too.
Okay.
See if this one works.
Look at this.
Where am I now?
Where's my textures?
Okay, never mind.
I'm out of I'm I'm out of town now
Where did I go?
I'm in a little town It's like that.
It's like the G mod texture.
We're missing the G mod textures.
Look at we I'm a little town right now I forgot to download
the source.
I forgot to download G mod the CS source
yay wait i want to let's go back to the other place i want
to be here this place is nice it's very festive
yay yay okay i should take off my hat i'm gonna take off my
hat i don't think it's right to wear it
And...
I need...
More hongbao!
No, not the hat.
No, the hat does not stay on at all.
Hat does not stay on.
Oh, that's fun though.
I had fun today.
I had fun just playing around here.
Gong Hei fach.
But before we go, I hope you all have a good...
Lunar New Year.
Lunar New Week.
New Year for the whole two weeks.
And I hope you guys spend a lot of good times with your
family and friends.
And eat lots of good food.
I'm going to make myself Nien Go.
That's right.
I can't wait to have a relaxing couple of weeks now.
No, no, I'm coming.
events sponsors surprises oh yeah and also also before i
forget oh wait that's balding woody that's it's not the
right one not the thing i wanted to show guys not that not
that but before i forget guys check out check out the new
year drought the new year voice pack i speak captainese in
there do um yeah it's the you guys want the voice pack and
also the limited edition buttons check it out i had a great
time it was fun it was fun just playing just you know moving
around just talking yeah as children yeah i don't know all
right final poses all right this is it this is your chance
to ask for final poses guys uh rice thank you for the
akasupa thank you thank you i've been unlocked by that uh
full lunar new year outfit for like 30 minutes by pay any
amount of money for that to become a full model so saying
thank you thank you thank you well funny you say that but
anyway guys final final poses what do you guys want oh shit
the twitch sponsors fuck all right never mind there's still
a couple of sponsors left i have to do how i'm gonna do the
run like i'm on my It's hard to do the run because like, you
know, because it's like, you know, I don't know what to, I
can't really do it.
Like, like the tracking won't let me do it very well.
No, Naxi, y'all paid more for that.
Thank you, this is a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Arms over.
No, but I will put my arms up.
I'll do, I'll do the final calibration for you guys.
Final calibration.
I'm calibrating.
Next sequence.
Thank you for the aqua soup.
Thank you.
Bye my dignity.
All right.
That should work now.
Let's see.
Can't believe you were making me hold red pockets while
doing this.
Is it working?
Did it work?
I can't tell.
Did it...
Did it work?
I don't know.
But...
I know how to do it.
It's this.
I can't see myself because I'm looking at the floor
I'm not quite not I technically did it I was look is that
the new SCP nope this is my look at this I could touch my
foot look at that I can touch my okay okay might look like
I'm like not flexible at all but i swear to god it's just my
legs are very long guys i swear to god
my legs are just super long here
i was thinking no i swear i'm doing it i swear i'm doing
it's just it's just my legs are long
Look, I can even do, wait, does this work?
What's that dance move called the, when you hold, you hold
this leg and then you're like, I could do that.
The funky chicken, yeah, I could do the funky chicken, look.
I hit my mic again
I can do it at disco Oh my god
Oh, uh, staying alive
Staying alive
All right, pose like a horse I just did
There All right.
I'm a guy here, everybody.
Happy New Year, everybody.
New Year, happy new year.
Happy birthday, everybody.
Take care of your family.
I hope you guys, everyone, have a very, very, very fun
festival.
I was like, how do I say this in Cantonese?
But I hope, all people, have a good, all people, have a
great time, great night.
enjoyed today's stream.
I did.
I enjoyed moving around for everybody.
It's like a fan.
This is like my fan.
I was like, oh, it's so hot.
Oh my God.
Fanning myself with money is like, oh my God, it's, thank
God I have all this money to fan myself with.
Oh my God.
yeah it's my weapon dude I don't I'm too scared I'm gonna
I'm I'm too scared to watch back my stream I'm because of
the quality of the sound I'm so I'm so scared of watching my
stream back because I don't want I don't want to know how
bad the audio is I really don't want to know
I'm too scared.
Anyway, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check,
get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Bye bye everyone!
Bye bye!